right for months you have heard me call
right here on this program the Muller
investigation a witch-hunt you've heard
the president say you've heard me say
it's the biggest abuse of power
corruption scandal in modern American
history tonight we're gonna break down
the scandal item by item step by step
based on three serious issues the
abusively biased partisan makeup of the
political investigation the focus of the
investigation on a single man we don't
have equal justice under the law rather
than an actual crime and third what is a
rampant double standard present in our
justice system today all right we get
started on May 17 2017 robert muller was
tasked with investigating fears that the
country of russia interfered with our
presidential election the year before
now given this was a hotly contested
subject well you think it would
obviously a political politically
charged issue you would expect robert
muller probably to be careful to appoint
a team of nonpartisan investigators that
didn't have any conflicts of interest
sadly the exact opposite happened his
first lead investigator the now fired
Peter struck the same guy that said that
Hillary Clinton should win this election
a hundred million to zero by the way the
same guy that said oh all sorts of
things about Donald Trump and talked
about an insurance policy just in case
he did win now his lead prosecutor
meeting Muller's Andrew Weissman the guy
the New York Times calls
Muller's pit bull actually attended
Hillary Clinton's election night party
well he's objective Weissman also
praised acting Attorney General Sally
Yates when she refused to follow orders
from her boss the President of the
United States Muller also appointed a
woman her name is jeanne ray she
previously served as an attorney for
Hillary Clinton that's right at the
Clinton Foundation now this looks really
really bad and it's only the tip of the
iceberg because Muller literally filled
his team of so-called objective
investigators with major Democratic
donors no Republicans people who donated
tens of thousands of dollars to the
Clintons the Obamas and others 14
of the 17 special counsel prosecutors
registered Democrats zero Republicans
and at this point Robert Muller might as
well have hired Maxine Waters and
Elizabeth Warren he's not even trying to
appear fair and it's no wonder that from
the very beginning this investigation
centered around one man one man only and
that's your President Donald Trump it's
the opposite of how our justice system
is supposed to work which brings us to
part 2 of our witch-hunt analysis
remember in the old Soviet Union they
investigated people and then they found
crimes in America we're supposed to
investigate crimes and find the
perpetrators and sadly here we are
investigating a man not a crime look at
Michael Flynn look at Papadopoulos look
at man afford stone jerome corsi they
share only one thing in common
connections to Donald Trump
Flynn Papadopoulos pled guilty to
process crimes caused by the
investigation itself and in the case of
Flynn the FBI didn't even think he was
lying but he ran out of money had to
sell his house and I'm pretty certain
that his son was threatened to be
investigated if he didn't sign the
papers and for example man affords
crimes nothing to do with Russia nothing
to do with collusion you have issues
that were previously resolved that date
back to 2007 loan applications and taxes
and no matter what Muller throws at
these men
it doesn't matter hours of
interrogations threats life in prison
well he's always offering to get out of
jail free card if they say what Muller
and his team want them to say by the way
with no evidence whatsoever needed of
any Trump Russia collusion nothing has
been uncovered zero even CNN's peak news
fake Jake Tapper admitted there's
literally no crime here you know why
because there isn't take a look so this
is look this is clearly not welcome news
for the president I don't wanna pretend
that is but once again I look at these
documents and I don't see any evidence
of conspiracy between members of the
Trump team and members of the Russian
government to interfere in the election
no conspiracy no collusion no crime what
we have though
is a political persecution by the way
this started way before Muller now
breaking tonight the hills John Solomon
is reporting during the presidential
election Donald Trump's allies were
constantly targeted by our own
intelligence apparatus at least six
people he's reporting tonight with
long-established ties to the FBI or US
Western intelligence agencies made
entrees to keep figures in the Trump
business organization or his
presidential campaign this all happening
between March and October 2016 in the
lead-up to the election and Solomon
continues nearly all of the contacts
involved the same overture a discussion
about possible dirt stolen emails
harmful to Hillary Clinton or
unsolicited business in London or Moscow
and get this according to the report
these contacts were likely efforts by
Obama's DOJ why to bolster claims made
in Hillary Clinton's bought and paid for
phony wise dossier that lying dossier
put together by Christopher Steele he
doesn't even stand by his own dossier he
can't corroborate anything in it or
verify anything in it with this is huge
news because they're plotting planning
and scheming and it brings us to the
third issue in our analysis the
disgusting despicable two-tiered system
of justice that shouldn't be in the
United States of America because in 2016
the Clinton campaign they funneled
millions and millions of dollars through
a law firm Perkins cuy in order to hire
an OP research firm in order to hire an
ex foreign spy that had deep Russia
connections to dig up dirt on Donald
Trump that spy Christopher Steele puts
together wholly uncorroborated
unverified dossier full of Russian lies
probably straight from the Kremlin and
instead of investigating the obvious
collusion Obama's DOJ commis FBI they
used that dirty campaign up research
they never verified they never
corroborated as the very basis to open
investigation into Donald Trump and by
the way get deep
into the Trump campaign by committing
fraud multiple times on the FISA Court
to get warrants against the Trump
campaign associate that's Carter Paige
they used it in a coordinated leak
strategy and they actually talked about
it
why would they have a leak strategy to
manipulate the American voters and today
it's the foundation of what is Robert
Muller's witch-hunt this gross
despicable double standard it doesn't
end there
remember uranium one let's talk about
this do we really care about Russian
interference in America Hillary
Clinton's Secretary of State one of nine
people including Eric Holder signing off
on sending twenty percent of our uranium
which is the foundational material for
nuclear weapons to the hostile regime of
Russia the hostile actor Vladimir Putin
in 2015 the New York Times reported
quote shortly after the Russians
announced their intention to acquire a
majority stake in uranium one well
former President Bill Clinton received
$500,000 in Moscow for a speech from a
Russian investment bank yep the same
bank with links to the Kremlin that was
promoting uranium 1 stock and it gets
even more sketchy during the transfer of
uranium 1 to Russia the Clinton
Foundation they received millions and
millions of dollars from the very people
involved in the deal and by the way in
the lead-up to this the FBI director
that I was Robert Muller well we had an
FBI informant inside of Putin's Network
right here in America and he was telling
the FBI about what he was witnessing
serious serious issues here's what he
told me when I had an opportunity to
talk to this informant and at some point
you became aware that Russia wanted to
get a foothold in the uranium industry
and that they were going to look at this
this conglomeration known but we now
know is uranium one and that deal was
going to give them that foothold if in
fact it was approved by nine government
agencies yes sir there was no question
about it
yeah and the FBI knew that the bureau
knew it
uranium one position was a part of a
long-term strategy a four-tier strategy
by the Russians were they telling you
that they had confidence that Clinton
would sign off on this deal absolute
confidence did they have confidence that
Obama would sign off on this deal they
were quite sure that Obama and the
administration who they had deemed and
and labeled as being very weak multiple
times would respond favorably so before
they approved it that informant
described issues involving bribery
extortion kickbacks money laundering
Putin's Network inside America to get a
foothold in our uranium industry the
foundational material for nuclear
weapons by the way Bob Muller happened
to be the FBI director at the time he
was the one being informed why would
they ever approve any such deal like
that so it was Robert Muller's Mary
banded democratic donors are they
investigating that CD link between the
Clintons and Russia and by the way of
course not what about Muller he was the
FBI director that was his guy that had
infiltrated Putin's Network in the
United States maybe he could be
investigated it has to do with Russia
nuclear materials why did they ever let
that happen that's because we now live
in a two-tier justice system one where
President Trump and anybody around him
or aggressively pursued for months on
end by a team of Democrats masquerading
as investigators the Clintons any other
Democrat they get away scot-free every
American should be very concerned and
worried by what is a completely unfair
precedent in this country and sadly most
of the mainstream media they are so
left-wing in their partisanship so
filled with anti-trump rage every second
minute hour of every day that they're
literally cheering Muller every single
move he makes with giddy anticipation
and excitement trembling with joy and
happiness sort of like Chris Matthews
getting a thrill up is like watching
Obama every time they hear the word
Russia Russia Russia even if
just indicted Oh intelligence officials
from Russia that will never be brought
to the US to be put on trial ever and
just to mention the name watch this this
guilty plea yesterday was really an
early Christmas present for all of the
congressional committees that are
investigating various elements of the of
the Russia case here I still AM of the
mind that this President may not serve
out his term from our reporting one
thing is clear he has been knocked off
balance here completely the question
becomes when do Republicans start to
turn untrim because that's the only
thing that's gonna get Trump out of
office and if this were a mafia
investigation Trump be indited under
Rico no question about it I spoke with a
source who's very close to Michael Cohen
who said to me today in no uncertain
terms Michael has the goods he has
extremely valuable information you have
somebody who's in Trump's innermost
circle for so long Chris who's known as
this fixer who knows where the bodies is
they are buried this is not the way a
high elected official is supposed to
talk it's the way guys talk to me when
they're wearing orange jumpsuits and
explaining why they got done wrong MP
are also today trying to link Donald
Trump jr. to the cone revelations from
yesterday Alba calling him a liar but
yeah hours later MP I NPR was forced to
backtrack in an editor's note writing
they mischaracterized on Junior's
statement these people are not looking
out for you the American people they're
looking ahead to the 2020 election
they're rooting for the president to be
legitimized to fail no matter the
consequences no matter the upset due to
the entire country not helping the
American people in any way